hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
home economics is a somewhat
old-fashioned term that you don't hear
that much today and for the ancient
Greeks particularly Aristotle in
politics book one that would be what we
call a play on Azzam where you're saying
the thing more times than it needs to be
said because household or home economics
is saying basically the same thing the
art of managing the resources of the
household prudently wisely effectively
the Greek term for this art or science
is economy K comes from the word Waco's
meaning house or extended household
which would include not only the nuclear
family but also extended relatives
servants retainers of various sorts and
whatever property it is that they own we
get the word economics from this and we
tend to think of economics as something
for the most part that it's you know the
vast economy out there and then we think
of the economy of the individual
household as being a tiny little unit
within that larger national or
international economy but really the the
original form of it is the household
itself and Aristotle is very interested
in thinking in a general way he's not
giving you specific advice here but in a
general way about what is household
management really supposed to be about
and you noticed as you read through this
that he is grappling with ideas that are
completely relevant today and he is also
combating ideas that we see cropping up
frequently today so one of the key
questions that he's asking is what is
the relationship between two different
disciplines or arts household management
economic a and what we can call wealth
acquisition Hamas DK you could also
think of this in terms of property
wealth clay
and compasses a lot of things it can
also be translated as possessions and
for the ancient Greeks as you see in in
politics book 1 there's a lot of
different kinds of property even people
can be property in the form of servitude
or slavery but there's also money and
money plays a major role in Aristotle's
thinking about this
so is household management just the same
thing as wealth acquisition that's the
way a lot of people look at it today you
just got to make some money and then
make that money work for you or stretch
it or budget it or things like that
there's actually a lot more to household
management than just making or
conserving money Aristotle does say that
the art of acquisition understood in a
certain way can be a legitimate part of
household management but if it's
understood in the wrong way it actually
falls outside of the scope of household
management and to conflate or confuse
the two in that case for example you
know back when day trading was a really
big thing a lot of people put their
their money into buying stocks online
and selling them and quite a few people
lost quite a bit of money doing so some
made money that's not actually managing
your household resources effectively
from an Aristotelian perspective it may
generate more wealth that you can then
use buy yourself a new car you know
start saving for college for your kids
or something like that but there's
there's other things that are more
germane to the household than simply
making as much money as possible so what
is Aristotle think that household
management is really about he thinks
that we need to be attentive and he
doesn't define what these are at this
point but this is something that we
could devote some thought to we need to
be attentive to the goods that are
either
needed or necessary or going beyond that
useful for life for Beals in Greek for
living a life together so of course what
would this include clothing shelter food
fuel all those sorts of issues we may
have a much wider scope today you know
some people consider Wi-Fi to be a basic
human right and if you do then that
would have to be part of household
management right now notice that he
doesn't just say life he says also for
community Koinonia for the community of
the household because the household
itself is a community and the larger
society that you live with it whether
that be one of a tribe and ethnos among
the barbarian people or that of a
village a coal may be a smaller
Association or that of the political
community the city-state the polis the
household has to be able to in some way
manage not just acquire but manage the
goods that it has to prioritize them to
deal with them store them for example
effectively maintain them in good proper
condition he also says that the
household by its very nature is in many
respects concerned with natural
production and use of goods what does he
mean by natural production well
Aristotle has in mind the sorts of
production of food that takes place
through farming or through hurting goats
or sheep or cattle or any of those other
sorts of things fishing I suppose would
be part of that for many people and then
there's many other goods that are
produced within the household through
various arts but they're coming from
nature so if you think about why it's
important to have sheep well the Sheep
provide you with wool right and the wool
then is spun into
red and the thread is placed on a loom
which then you know is turned into cloth
the cloth is then sewn into clothing and
go on and on and on and on
I suppose you know I don't know if the
Greeks actually had knit sweaters but
you could have yarn as well and knit
those those sweaters but all of that is
is production that takes place in
ancient times within the household we in
our modern way of living we don't do
very much natural production at all if
we do it's probably in an elite and
artisan sort of way or it's because
we're so desperately poor that we can't
afford anything else and we need to
produce it ourselves or we could just be
in to DIY things right but for the
ancient Greeks that was really a central
part of what the household did and
that's the way it was through most of
human history and in most cultures the
other thing that he brings up is a
household will engage most likely in
some trade or barter with others not for
the purpose primarily of acquiring
wealth in the sense of getting more out
of the bargain but precisely so that
they can supply themselves with the
goods that are needed for life and
community which they're not able to
procure themselves so buying salt is a
prime example salt only available in
certain areas it might be mined more
effectively in some places than others
and so you might trade some of your
barley or your your corn which for us
Americans of course we think of what
other people call maize but corn was
your your wheat or other grains or you
might be trading wool or you might be
trading your olive oil or something like
that to get that salt that you you want
and we could go on and on and on with
examples Aristotle also talks about some
fundamentally mistaken views in his
point of view
what are these mistaken views we can
recognize these in our own time where
the household is turned in
something like a money-making Enterprise
perhaps a factory perhaps some sort of
trading post perhaps something else
that's supposed to simply generate more
and more wealth and Aristotle says the
fundamental mistake here is thinking
that household management is primarily
about safeguarding wealth in the form of
money or about increasing wealth without
limit and now why would this be such a
issue in his own time well he brings up
the case of King Midas for example King
Midas was rich as it could possibly be
every single thing he touched turned
into gold and yet he couldn't eat
anything of course because if he they
didn't have bananas back then but just
imagine he's grabbing a banana to peel
it and suddenly it turns into gold now
he could say hey who wants a gold banana
let me trade this to somebody right but
whoever he traded it to I suppose you'd
have to be awfully careful don't shake
their hand or they're gonna turn into
gold but whoever he traded it would give
him something else which then he would
touch and it turns into gold and then
it's no longer edible this is a mistaken
set of priorities there are people who
in fact become misers right and hoard
vast amounts of money but they don't use
the money for the purpose that money
actually has buying stuff that isn't
money buying the things that we need for
a good life or even just for living so
the notion that we should be orienting
the household primarily around
safeguarding money or making as much
money as possible or piling up as many
goods as possible Aristotle thinks is a
fundamentally mistaken set of
prioritizations that will not lead
people to the good life they'll actually
lead people into unhappiness you might
think
although Aristotle doesn't discuss this
about the you know recently identified
phenomenon of hoarding as an example of
this as well in that case the
things that are being hoarded often do
not possess genuine value or they cease
to possess it because they're not kept
in good condition which is what the
house hold management skill would would
in fact do but they're being hoarded up
and then you know they have to bring in
people to throw all that stuff away or
sift through it for the few nuggets of
good saleable materials that are there
Aristotle also discusses one other thing
that I think is particularly important
to keep in mind he says that the art of
household management it does include
this art of wealth acquisition but we
can understand this on an analogy to
medicine not everybody needs to be a
doctor you don't have to have a medical
degree or license in order to make your
household a healthy place you don't
require that level of knowledge or
commitment
or you might say single-mindedness
similarly it is a good thing to know
something about saying how money works
how to balance a budget how to do you
know setting aside money for a rainy day
how to make good trades how to buy
things on sale rather than at a premium
price you know for example lining up
outside the Apple store to get the
latest iPhone at a premium price not
good household management right waiting
until it goes on sale and then acquiring
it at a deep discount probably part of
good household management but you don't
need to be a financial wizard or you
know a master of the various properties
that you're buying and selling and using
in order to do that so he ends up saying
that here we go in as much as in a way
it does belong to the householder and
the ruler to see even the health in a
way it doesn't belong to them but to the
position also with regard to wealth in a
way it's the affair of the householder
in a way it's not but it is a matter for
the subsidiary art that means that the
art of wealth acquisition should always
be subordinate to and guided by the art
of household management it should never
be the one single thing that's actually
running the show and the person who's
most qualified in wealth acquisition is
not necessarily the person who should be
running the household so you see that
for Aristotle wealth acquisition is part
but only a limited part of household
management household management
identifies and works with and
understands a whole different set of
goods going beyond the scope of the
promise TK or the wealth acquiring art
you